let's get internationally drunk
we are even there with international
dream customs you like the only real
American drinking custom that bingeing I
feel like the alcohol and like other
countries is stronger I think we're
gonna drink less but it'd be more joy no
this is Eugene shoot I think we're gonna
drink more and II think I should be
exciting that I love learning about new
ways to drink alcohol let's do this
[Music]
I love gin see I can't do Jim I don't
like James it is not my jam you guys
don't like drinking Christmas look at
that bottle it's just much cooler than
what we drink like it looks like a
[ __ ] potion smells like a lemon a gin
kind of oh it burns I know you can't use
your hands
I suppose the deep throated or nipple
the tip well now I know why next popular
that went right a big mouth
congratulations and it doesn't burn I
think it has a good taste I think it's
refreshing if I tried to tug this though
I would straight-up vomit everywhere oh
wait Kristin you shoot it didn't take a
shot on the liquor like that there's no
fun to be had there the gin and the beer
is a really really nice confident also
looks like a handsome man and a
beautiful lady it just makes me wonder
what like a night out and the
Netherlands must be like if this is like
their version of a shot Nick just went
down on some Netherlands wouldn't be the
first time [ __ ] is going on this isn't
the first sorry in this scenario I'm the
one who bought the beer because I have
money anything that allows me to make
friends while drinking I'm about it my
friend
you're gonna get triple herpes you took
rose and now they're just a little bit
of foam left and I'm going to Ricky
let's lick that [ __ ] what did you forget
to do you know bars already smell
terrible
beer on the ground it's kind of crazy I
think no matter where you go in the
world people don't like foam flick it
out that was soaking so I pretty sure
just like bring this tradition to the
homey
[Music]
so quite if we had to name our friends
repo would it be Briana you're holding
your hands out like you're keeping the
demons at bay
Freddy's fishes Oh would you bang the
fireball mascot we have to lift it
together and put our mouse on and tilt
it together I'm not convinced this is
real I think you're making all this [ __ ]
up Chris you're breathing really loud
what you've done a shot ski but you've
never seen hey you know I know how I
like to risk my life water
mouth-breather hey I watched Kelsey
sleep once and she breezed over mount
one so we are all different heights the
tallest person becomes the shortest
person I've ever taken in my life
I mean what we need a team name let's be
called
I'm wasted well get ready because
Korea's next
welcome to Korea winner drinkers click
we've just found out Korea's got a [ __ ]
ton of rules what are they just if it is
just if you're older you're better the
reverence to elders give me a drink and
being just generally classy [ __ ] you
see this one weird black hair Korea
you're making this too complicated hold
your [ __ ] cup bro
never had that before that was delicious
if anyone offers you a drink you could
never refuse it I thought America at a
binge drinking situation yes this is the
binge drinking situation okay so you
have to elect someone to drink it for
you so he would you like to take if I'm
Briana's black night she owes me a wish
a little shoulder rub I understand you
jeans so much more that this is the
Korean drinking fish my wish is for you
to say the meanest thing you can think
of to these two oh my parents may be
poor all their shots I'd be pissed
usually when I go to bars no one's like
respecting me like that I want to go to
Korea Asia your scatterbrain is fun okay
but that's no little bit sometimes you
just sound drunk and I know you're not
that's okay it's a speech impediment I
think you're a hard worker you're an
independent why I find hilarious you're
so funny
you know what if you guys like made out
it out a little bit
No
[Music]
where'd you get a snack oh I went to
look at the snap and I was hold a baby
boy once you have time to hold a baby
for it where it's not really rude I
never tried aquavit oh [ __ ] it smells
like black liquor that is the cutest
things ever come here wait you have to
sing a song oh yeah
Omar we're just gonna [ __ ] sing
because that's what Swedes do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was so bad
I feel like my throat just got [ __ ] by
sanitizer as soon as we finish the song
I wanted to go another one wouldn't be
going to be in a whole bar where
everyone's sake of all the traditions
this is the one that we're gonna keep
this is American tradition now we have a
bigger military I'm sorry it's ours
oh saying I am so saying I'm trying to
find love
really maybe it's me it's not you men
are afraid honestly it's a two-way
street
I'm [ __ ] busy I think it might help
your cause to not have sex on the first
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't love with your vagina you put your
heart and your mind sponsored by Sweden
nanaka
[Music]
the last drink whooping one more one
more tradition we have to elect a tomato
tomato I say tomato you aren't you elect
a tomato okay raise your hand if you
think you didn't should be the tostada
well Freddy's [ __ ] it's gotta be
pretty [ __ ] so sure why not why not
so are we like in Savannah and like a
land no we're in the [ __ ] country
Georgia don't drink yeah you can't drink
it experience a lot of different
traditions we deep throated glasses we
threaten other countries I think that
whenever you're friends with someone
you're not truly good friends with them
until you're drunk with them this made
me want to like travel more now like we
need to see the world this is so fine
[Applause]
Kelsey is there God I don't know are
there [ __ ] magicians
there are magician you might not agree
about a higher power but we all agree
that drinking brings us together okay I
have three hours of work left this is
[ __ ] done good night